now then Israel has confirmed it is
responsible for two simultaneous attacks
in Syria one targeted leppo
International Airport which is currently
out of service the other strike hits the
capital Damascus Damascus Airport in
fact let's go to our correspondent Ali
Hashim who's on the 11 and Israel border
so tell us about these strikes Ali and
and how they fit into everything that's
going
on Nick I'll tell you about the strikes
in a minute but first let me give you
the latest update from here from the
leane Israeli border uh we have reports
of several missiles that has been
launched from the Lebanese borders
towards Israel so this is what we have
and we will follow up on this maybe for
more details now with respect to what
happened in Damascus and Aleppo Israeli
uh uh airplanes hit the both the
airports in Damascus uh and Aleppo and
now both airports are are out of service
according to Israeli military
spokesperson this attack comes as a
retaliation to several shells that were
launched from the Syrian border towards
Israel and also he said that there are
going to be more um strikes on uh
Targets in Syria now this comes as the
the Iranian foreign minister Was
preparing to land in Syria however the
air strike on the Damascus International
Airport made Force the Iranian foreign
minister to changes his
route Ali thanks for that Ali Hashim
reporting there from the border with Le
and Israel thank you